>> ♪ ♪
>> KEVIN MCCARTHY BOOSTING
CONTROVERSY DEMOCRATS FROM HE
HOUSE COMMITTEES REMOVING SCHIFF
AND SWALWELL.
REPUBLICANS SAY SWALWELL CAN'T
BE TRUST AFTER HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH A SUSPECTED CHINESE FRY AND
SCHIFF SHOWN THE DOOR FOR THERE.
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
IN PLAIN SIGHT.
IT WAS BORN OUT BY THE REPORT.
THE OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE IS
FAR WORSE THAN ANYTHING THAT
RICHARD NIXON DID.
THIS IS MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN
WATERGATE.
>> AND ILHAN OMAR REMOVED FROM
THE FOREIGN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
OVER ANTI-SEMITIC COMMENTS.
DEMOCRATS SET A PRECEDENCE OF
KICKING MEMBERS OFF COMMITTEES.
>> WE TOLD THEM YOU SHOULD NOT
DO THAT BECAUSE IF IT'S GOOD FOR
THE GOOSE, IT'S GOOD FOR THE
GANDER.
ILHAN OMAR SAID THINGS THAT ARE
REPREHENSIBLE.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE USING
COMMUNITY LEADERSHIP.
>> IF YOU WANT TO CHANGE THE
RULES, WE WILL LIVE BY YOUR
RULES.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
JUDGE, THE DEMOCRATS DON'T SEE
PAST ONE NEWS CYCLE.
McCONNELL SAID IF YOU LOWER THE
THRESHOLD FOR JUDGES THAT WILL
HURT YOU AND THE MAJORITY ON THE
SUPREME COURT ARE CONSERVATIVES.
>> THE DECISION TO MAKE THESE --
THESE ARE MOMENTOUS THINGS.
TO HAVE THE MAJORITY TAKE
SOMEONE OFF A COMMITTEE BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT A MEMBER OF THE
PARTY.
IF MCCARTHY DIDN'T DO THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE WOULD BE UPSET WITH
HIM.
THEY DID IT TO OUR PARTY.
THERE IS GOOD REASON.
WHEN YOU HAVE SWALWELL THIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH FANG-FANG.
SHE WORKED IN HIS CAMPAIGN AND
PERSONALLY INVOLVED WITH HIM.
AND SCHIFF IS LYING THROUGH HIS
TEETH.
THIS GUY IS PERJURYING HIMSELF
IN FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE DOESN'T BELONG ON
A COMMITTEE.
AND ILHAN OMAR HAS SHOWN HOW
HERE HER ANTI-SEMITISM.
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE MCCARTHY
ON THE FACT THERE IS THE
IMPEACHMENT OF MAYORKAS.
THEY ARE GOING TO TOWN.
>> SCHIFF GUARANTEED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD BE IN
JAIL.
HE SAID I KNOW THIS IS
HAPPENING.
>> YES, AND NEVER OFFERED ANY
EVIDENCE BECAUSE AS JUDGE SAYS
HE IS A LIAR.
IF WERE NOT FOR THE REPUBLICANS
RIGHT NOW, THESE CLOWNS WOULD
HAVE TENURE DESPITE LACKING ANY
CREDIBILITY.
SCHIFF CREATED HOAXES.
SWALWELL IS A SECURITY SIEVE AND
OMAR ILHAN, OH BROTHER!
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> IT SHOWS YOU ANOTHER CONTRAST
BETWEEN DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
DUE TO MEDIA SCRUTINY,
REPUBLICANS CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE
NUTS FOR VERY LONG.
RIGHT WING NOISEMAKERS.
LET'S ONE QUARTER THE ABSURDITY
OF ADAM SCHIFF COME AND GO LIKE
THAT.
LOOK AT GEORGE SANTOS.
IF HE SURVIVES I WILL BE
SURPRISED.
THE DEMOCRATICS CAN STEAK AROUND
FOREVER.
MAXINE WATERS OR ADAM SCHIFF.
LIKE SWALWELL'S FLATULENCE.
>> IS WHAT IS GOOD FOR THE GOOSE
IS GOOD FOR THE GANDER.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD THAT BEFORE.
>> FROM TOP GUN.
>> YES.
I LIKE THIS STORY BETTER IF WE
COULD SEE THEM GET THE BOOT.
I WANT TO SEE THE SERGEANT OF
ARMS COME INTO THE COMMITTEE
HEARING AND GRAB THEM BY THE
ELBOW AND ESCORT THEM OUT LIKE
A BOUNCER.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THEM BEING
BOOTED.
I LIKE THE IDEA THAT REPUBLICANS
WON ON THE NUMBERS.
IF THEY KICKED OUT PAUL GOLSER
AND MARJORIE TAYLOR GREEN,
REPUBLICANS KICKED OUT SCHIFF,
OMAR AND SWALWELL THAT'S 3-2.
I AM GLAD SCHIFF IS OFF
A COMMITTEE.
HE IS A LIAR AND A?
>> SACK OF SCHIFF.
>> I WAS GOING TO WITH LEAKER.
>> WOW!
>> THIS WOULD BE LIKE -- OH,
BOY.
>> JUST KIDDING.
THIS WOULD BE LIKE ME SAYING I
AM ONLY ALLOWED TO INTERRUPT
JESSICA.
IT JESSICA INTERRUPTS ME, THAT'S
NOT ALLOWED.
>> I LIKE THAT RULE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT'S THE CREDO YOU LIVE BY.
A FEW DAYS AGO YOU GOT JEALOUS
THAT OTHER PEOPLE WERE
INTERRUPTING ME AND YOU COULD
NOT.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREEN WHO IS
A BIG NAME IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THE VIDEO IS DOWN BECAUSE
DR. DRE WAS MAD BECAUSE SHE USED
HIS MUSIC.
SHE WAS KICKED OFF COMMITTEES
FOR ADVOCATING FOR VIOLENCE
AGAINST DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT FOR BEING
WRONG.
WE HAVE A DEMOCRATIC CONTROLLED
SENATE AND A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT IN THE HOUSE THAT IS
MOSTLY SYMBOLIC.
ILHAN OMAR'S RELIED ON A VOTE
AND THE GOP IS NOT GOING TO PUT
HER BACK ON THE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE.
ON THE SCHIFF POINT A LOT OF
WHAT HE SAID TURNED OUT TO BE
WRONG.
I WOULD BE INTERESTED TO SEE
A MONTAGE OF REPUBLICANS HYPING
THE DURHAM REPORT.
HOW THAT WAS GOING TO EXPOSE THE
DEEP STATE IN WAYS WE COULD NOT
UNDERSTAND.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> HE SAID HE SAW THE EVIDENCE.
THERE IS THE DIFFERENCE.
HE IS A LAWYER WHO SAID I SAW
THE EVIDENCE.
>> SOMEONE AT HOME MAKE
A MONTAGE FOR ME.
I WANT TO SEE PEOPLE LIKE JIM
JORDAN, PROMINENT REPUBLICANS
SAYING JUST YOU WAIT AND SEE.
THE JUDGE LAUGHED AT HIM.
>> THAT COULD WORK IF ANY OF
THOSE PEOPLE SAID I KNOW BECAUSE
I HAVE SEEN AND I GUARANTEE IT.
THAT'S WHAT SCHIFF SAID.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
>> THAT'S TOTALL